BUILDING.
>> AND WE'RE UNDERWAY.
ROOKLYN.
SWITCHING HANDS, HE GETSIFFINS
.
>> JOE HARRIS
HARDEN.
EARLY.
LAYS IT IT.
GRIFFIN JUST TOOK A SHOTD YESY
CHARLOTTE.
HARDEN, GOOD MOVE. UPSTAIRS,
AND THE
THAT'S WHAT THE NETSO
BE CAREFUL OF.
>>LLS, WILL IT POP?
UP, MILLS.
UP.
NAILS IT.
KEVIN COURT.
ANKLE BREAKING THREE. NEGATE .
HARDEN OFF THE SCREEN.
THE ROLL.
AND THE CLAMMERARDEN IS GOINGT
AND MAKE IT.
JOE HARRIS,
SPLASH
THIS HIGH POWERED SECOND
KEVIN DURANT BACK IN.
THE CLOCK.
DURANT,
>> THEY HAD 17 YESTERDAY. OUTT
HARDEN BOUNCE, BRUCE BROWN. T.
BROOKLYN,
AGAIN, AT SOME POINT, BRADLEY
BEAL IS GOING PATTY
MILLS EARLY, HARRELL GETS
RIGHT TO HIS SPOT.M BEMBRY,
BEAL TRYING TO
NOBODY HOME, THEY LOST
HARRELL, W SHOT.
DINWIDDIE DRIVES IN ON JOE
HARRIS AND HITS THE HARRELL.
IAN: THAT IS NINE TURNOVERS OT
SPIN.
CLAXTON.
DID THAT HAPPEN? BOTL
WISE ABOUT SOME THINGS.
SARA: WHAT STRONG.
GETS THE BEAL.
YO HARRIS.
THAT IS LITERALLY SHOOTING
THE ROOKIE FROM GONZAGA IS I
NETS CONTINUE